[applause]
[music]
we now come
to the election of the
president of the european parliament in accordance with our
rules of procedure, member of parliament
verhofstadt informed me a few minutes ago that
he had withdrawn his candidacy that had already been announced
[music]
nice
because there was no candidate and no female candidates
the absolute majority  of the
votes cast we come to a
second ballot in
June
minute again a different according to
article 16 paragraph 1 of the rules of procedure
in the fourth ballot only the two
members can be candidates
who should have received the number of votes in the third ballot
these are the manufacturers and celebrate
[music  ]